Have NO regrets!
If you are afraid of starting something new
if you are thinking about quitting your business
if you’re having a really hard time with something
having a really hard time making a decision
a framework that might help you is fast-forward your life
to when you’re 80 years old and think back
“Am I going to regret not doing this?
Am I going to regret not having bet on myself and taking that chance?”
If you look at people who are on their deathbed
and you look at what they wish they could’ve changed on their lives
the most common answer that comes back is
“I regret that I didn’t take more chances.”
Don’t be that person. Bet on yourself.
Take your chances now while you can still take your shot.
One of my favorite stories is about the founder of Amazon
Jeff Bezos. When he was 30 years old
he was the youngest ever Vice President at his company.
It was an investment banking company.
He was making a 6-figure salary
and he saw the growth of the internet and he said
“I’m going to do this crazy thing and start this business on the internet.
I’m going to quit my job, my high-paying job
move my wife to Seattle to start all over again
start from scratch with nothing and start this internet company”
when at the time people didn’t know about the internet.
They said, “What are you doing, Jeff?
What the heck are you doing?
You are on the fast-track, man.
You’re 30 years old, the youngest ever Vice President at this company
you’re making 6 figure salary
why would you throw it all away to start this thing on the internet?
What’s the internet? Are you kidding me?”
And what helped him make that difficult decision was that
he didn’t want to live his life with regret.
Here’s one of my favorite quotes from him as he
was explaining this decision that he had to go through.
“So I wanted to project myself forward to age 80 and say
‘Okay, now I’m looking back on my life.
I want to have minimized the number of regrets I have.
And you know, I knew that when I was 80
I was not going to regret having tried this.
I was not going to regret trying to participate in this thing called the Internet
that I thought was going to be a really big deal.
I knew that if I failed I wouldn't regret that
but I knew the one thing I might regret is not ever having tried.
And I knew that that would haunt me every day.”
So have no regrets. Bet on yourself.
Take your shot while you still can
and believe.
You guys liked this video,
let me know what your shot is
let me know how you’re betting on yourself
and you’re not living with regrets.
Leave a comment below.
You liked the video, give it a thumbs-up.
And click on my face to subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.